And if you've got a Bible, I would invite you to turn with me to John chapter 11.
So John chapter 11.
It's also found there in your worship guides.
But as you're turning there, maybe go in your mind's eye to the airport.
I'm sure there's places you'd rather be than the airport today.
But you are heading there for your flight.
You're running a little bit late, but you get there just in time to check in your bags.
And you get through security.
And as you're huffing and puffing, you run up to the screen that says departures,
and you find your flight.
And right beside it, you read that dreaded word in red, delayed.
And you just can't help but groan as you see that word delayed.
About a month ago, my brother came to visit.
And it was great to see him.
This happened to him.
He was flying to Alabama, got stopped in Denver, and his flight was delayed.
But you may remember that day, not because you necessarily know him,
but because it was the day that most of us were hunkered down in a basement somewhere
because we were waiting on a tornado to arrive, or listening to James Spann
and keeping our eye on the weather.
That was why his flight was delayed, because there's no way you should be flying in weather like that.
So there was a delay, but it was for his good.
Well, John chapter 11 begins with a delay that was much more disappointing.
But it was also for a much greater good.
Word has come to Jesus that his friend Lazarus is sick,
and it looks like he is not going to pull through.
Lazarus' sisters, Mary and Martha, are the ones who have sent word to him.
And they've gotten in touch with Jesus not just to inform him about what is happening,
and not just to kind of invite him to come and pay his last respects,
but rather they get in touch with him because they want him to heal Lazarus.
They had seen him heal total strangers.
Surely he would heal his friend whom he loved.
But then the text says something very puzzling.
It says, he loved them, Lazarus, Mary and Martha.
So when he heard that Lazarus was ill, he stayed two days longer where he was.
Now you might expect it to say something like, he heard he was ill,
so he arose immediately and went to his friend Lazarus and healed him.
But that's not what it says.
It says he delayed two days.
Then when Jesus finally turns up, Lazarus is dead.
Now you can imagine the disappointment of Mary and Martha when Jesus arrives.
They were going through such a painful time.
And now they see Jesus and you can imagine the disappointment they must have felt.
But from our perspective we can see that this delay was for a much greater good.
So follow along with me now as we read this passage beginning where Jesus arrives in John 11 and verse 17.
It says, now when Jesus came, he found that Lazarus had already been dead in the tomb four days.
Bethany was near Jerusalem about two miles off.
And many of the Jews had come to Martha and Mary to console them concerning their brother.
So when Martha heard that Jesus was coming, she went and met him.
But Mary remained seated in the house.
Martha said to Jesus, Lord, if you had been here,
my brother would not have died.
But even now I know that whatever you ask from God, God will give you.
Jesus said to her, your brother will rise again.
Martha said to him, I know that he will rise again in the resurrection on the last day.
Jesus said to her, I am the resurrection and the life.
Whoever believes in me, though he died, yet shall he live.
And everyone who lives and believes in me shall never die.
Do you believe this?
She said to him, Yes, Lord, I believe that you are the Christ, the Son of God who is coming into the world.
When she had said this, she went and called her sister Mary saying in private,
the teacher is here and is calling for you.
And when she heard it, she rose quickly and went to him.
Jesus had not yet come into the village, but was still in the place where Martha had met him.
When the Jews who were with her in the house, consoling her, saw Mary rise quickly and go out,
they followed her, supposing that she was going to the tomb to weep there.
Now when Mary came to where Jesus was and saw him, she fell at his feet, saying to him,
Lord, if you had been here, my brother would not have died.
When Jesus saw her weeping and the Jews who had come with her also weeping,
he was deeply moved in his spirit and greatly troubled.
And he said, Where have you laid him?
They said to him, Lord, come and see. Jesus wept.
So the Jews said, See how he loved him.
But some of them said, Could not he who opened the eyes of the blind also have kept this man from dying?
Then Jesus deeply moved again, came to the tomb.
It was a cave and a stone lay against it.
Jesus said, Take away the stone.
Martha, the sister of the dead man, said to him, Lord, by this time there will be an odor for he has been dead four days.
Jesus said to her, Didn't I not tell you that if you believed you would see the glory of God?
So they took away the stone.
Jesus lifted up his eyes and said, Father, I thank you that you have heard me.
I knew that you always hear me, but I said this on account of the people standing around that they may believe that you sent me.
When he had said these things, he cried out with a loud voice.
Lazarus, come out.
The man who had died came out.
His hands and feet bound with linen strips and his face wrapped with a cloth.
Jesus said to them, unbind him and let him go.
This is the word of the Lord.
Let's pray.
Lord, your word is powerful.
You speak and the dead are raised to life.
Lord, I pray that you would speak to us this morning and that your words would change us.
Pray this in Jesus mighty name.
Amen.
I know all of us know what it is like to suffer in one way or another.
We can easily identify with Mary and Martha here in the loss of their brother.
And perhaps you can also identify with their disappointment.
You know what it's like to ask Jesus for help, to ask him for healing.
You prayed and you prayed, but nothing seemed to happen.
And so you wonder, is he even there?
Or maybe if he's there and he loves us, why doesn't he do something?
Our passage this morning shows us that even when we do not know what God is doing
or why he is delaying, we can still know that he is motivated by love
in what he is doing for us.
We may not be able to see his hand, but we can trust his heart.
We can know that even though we do not understand what is going on,
we can know that he loves us and is at work for the good of his friends.
So in our passage, we see four assurances of Jesus' love.
So I want us to just look at those four things together.
We see Jesus' love in this.
One, he came despite the threat.
All right, so while those with Lazarus wondered why Jesus was delaying,
those with Jesus were actually wondering why he went in the first place.
In the passage just before what we actually have in our reading, in our worship guides,
you see that the disciples are confused as to why Jesus would go.
You see, there had been attempts on his life, multiple attempts on his life,
in that very region recently.
It was dangerous to go.
So Jesus says, let us go to Judea again and they cannot believe it.
They say, Rabbi, the Jews were just now seeking to stone you.
Are you going to go there again?
In other words, what are you thinking?
You do not understand that your life is being threatened.
After all those things transpire, we're told that it was then at this point,
after the healing of Lazarus that we just read about,
that the plans were made, definite plans to put Jesus to death.
So what goes on here leads right to the cross.
So where he was going was incredibly dangerous.
He knew that and yet he went.
You know, heroes are often described as those people who,
when other people are running away from danger, they are running towards the danger.
If you think of like 9-11, when everybody is running away from the Twin Towers,
you look back to think about first responders, the policemen and the firefighters
who are running in the direction of the towers to rescue as many people as they can.
Why does Jesus go back to this place where he knows his life is under threat?
Because he loves us.
He's going so that we might be saved.
This was true for this family here in the raising of Lazarus,
but it is also true for us as well.
He knew that going to Lazarus would mean ultimately going to the cross.
Why does he go into the cross and suffer the cause?
He loves us and he was prepared to die for us.
So if his delay in whatever it is that you are longing for causes you to doubt his love,
look at the cross.
That's how much he loves you.
So he came despite the threat, but he also came secondly,
speaking the truth.
In love, he speaks the truth.
So we read that when he arrived in Bethany, Martha went out to meet him.
When she got to him, she expressed her disappointment.
Do you remember what she said?
She said, Lord, if you had been here, my brother would not have died.
And I'm amazed though that her disappointment is still mingled with a kind of dogged, persistent faith.
But even now I know that whatever you ask of God, he will give it to you.
So before I move on, could I just say that what Martha says here is just a beautiful example of prayer.
She speaks to the Lord with this raw honesty expressing exactly what she is feeling.
She's expressing her hurt to him.
And yet she is calling out to him with persistent yet imperfect faith.
So how does Jesus respond?
Well, he responds by telling her a truth that she needs to hear.
He tells her a truth that grounds her.
I don't know if you've ever seen the Hunger Games movies or you've read the novels.
I don't know if you're expecting to hear about Hunger Games on a day celebrating resurrection in life.
But in the third one of the novels, Mockingjay, there's a character called Peta who's been taken away by the enemy, essentially.
And he's been brainwashed and he's got a really loose grip on reality and it's scary.
But now he's back with people who are friends of his.
And it's hard to know for him what is real, what's a real memory, what's a false memory.
And so his friends come up with a kind of a game, if you will, that helps him to see what reality is.
When he's in doubt, he just says these words, real or not real.
He'll say something that say real or not real and they'll say real or they'll say not real.
And it ultimately leads to a point when his friend Katniss, when he says to her, you love me, real or not real.
And she answers real.
But here Jesus is assuring Martha of his love by giving her some reality to be grounded in.
When he says what he says to her, he isn't kind of offering her a band-aid on her like gaping wound.
Like thinking that's going to instantly make it better just by hearing the truth.
No, but he is giving her solid ground to put her feet on when everything else is giving way around her.
He's putting down an anchor, if you will, in the midst of the storm, in the fog and confusion of grief.
He looks at her and he says real.
We live in a confusing world and our feelings are such unreliable guides.
And we need truth from outside of ourselves to ground us in reality.
And the truth that we need more than anything else is what Jesus says to Martha.
So what is it?
Well, it begins by saying your brother will rise again in verse 23.
And she thinks he's just speaking about a resurrection kind of at the end of time.
But that's not what he's talking about.
He's talking about not something that's going to happen in the distant future,
but something that is right in front of her in the present.
And the thing that is right in front of her in the present is himself.
Here, Martha is saying, yes, one day there's going to be a resurrection.
But what she doesn't realize is that she is standing in the very presence of the one who is the resurrection and is the life.
So he says to her, I am the resurrection and the life.
Whoever believes in me, though he die, yet shall he live.
And everyone who lives and believes in me shall never die.
He's not just talking about a kind of a concept.
He is talking about himself and he is present with her in the midst of her grief.
I saw a clip a few days ago of Tanner from Love on the Spectrum.
He was talking about how much he loves Jack Black and he was being interviewed.
He said, one day I want to meet Jack Black and they played a video of Jack Black giving him a message on the screen.
And as the video is playing, Jack Black runs around the corner.
And Tanner is just absolutely elated to meet Jack Black.
He's just giving him hugs.
So he's thinking about, one day I want to meet him and then he sees this message from him.
And then he realizes, no, he is actually right here beside me.
So here in our text, we see Martha saying, like, yes, there's going to be a resurrection on the last day.
And I hear what you're saying, but Jesus is saying, look, I'm standing right in front of you.
So right the way throughout John's gospel and throughout the ministry of Jesus,
he made it clear that he is the I am.
He is God himself present among us dwelling with us.
He is the source of life. He is the one who has the power of resurrection.
He is the living reality that the truth points to.
And he's about to demonstrate this by raising Lazarus from the dead.
So the truth she needs to see more than anything isn't just an idea.
It is a person and that is Jesus.
So this Easter, we're not just being invited to an idea to just ponder some things.
I hope we all do ponder what Easter is all about.
But ultimately, we're being invited to a living person, Jesus, who is the resurrection and the life.
When everything else gives way, this truth holds.
Jesus is our life.
So he comes not only with truth.
He also comes thirdly with tears.
Jesus doesn't just tell her truth.
We see also Jesus weeping.
In the next scene of the account, Martha's sister Mary comes to see Jesus
and Mary is weeping.
Others around Mary are weeping.
And in her tears, she falls at Jesus' feet.
And she says the exact same words her sister said earlier.
She says, Lord, if you had been here, my brother would not have died.
But although Jesus hears the same statement from her, he doesn't respond in the same way.
He deals with her individually.
What we actually see here is an emotional response from Jesus.
He gives truth to Martha, but he gives tears to Mary.
We read that he is deeply moved and troubled.
And we read these two wonderful words, Jesus wept.
And reading this makes you ponder.
Like, since Jesus knows what he's about to do, why is he crying?
Like, surely he walks up on these people crying and he thinks,
like, if you only knew what I knew, you would be rejoicing right now.
Like, I've got the truth and I'm about to raise lasers from the dead.
If you only knew, you'd be happy like I am happy.
But that's not what Jesus does.
He weeps.
Why?
Because he is a savior who weeps with those who weep.
Jesus loves us so much that he is willing to fully embrace our humanity,
even our sorrows, even if it is but for a moment, he weeps with us in our sadness.
In Isaiah 53, back in the Old Testament, hundreds of years before this,
it told us that the Messiah, the Lord's servant, was one who was a man of sorrows
and acquainted with grief.
He opens up his heart to those who are grieving, even to the point of tears.
Now isn't this interesting?
It tells us that truth doesn't immediately drive tears away.
Here in Jesus, we can see that tears don't necessarily indicate a lack of faith
or spiritual immaturity.
You can believe the truth and grieve your losses.
Both of those things can be true at the same time.
This is what Jesus does.
People think, you know, when it comes to church, you've got to come like pasting a shiny smile on
as though everything was okay.
You've got it all together.
We know the truth.
We know that we'll be with the Lord one day.
We're not touched by any of this sadness.
That's not the example that Jesus gives.
He believes the truth and he weeps with us in our pain.
We know that we're grieving and we can believe.
So why does Jesus weep because he truly loves us?
But you know, sorrow isn't the only emotion he expresses here.
When it says that he was deeply moved, now this is something that like Bible commentators
and scholars really, you know, go back and forth on.
When it says he was deeply moved, that literally conveys anger.
He's angry as he is there near the tomb.
So we might get been out of shape and wonder, well, like, is he sympathizing in sorrow with
our tears or is he angry?
Well, both of those things can be true at the same time as well.
Now, he's not like angry at like Mary for crying.
Like we've already we've already seen that he's weeping with her.
So what is going on here is he can see more than anybody else can see.
He can sympathize with Mary and others who are weeping.
He is sitting with them in their grief and yet he sees the bigger picture.
He sees the devastating effects of sin and unbelief.
He sees the enemy of death.
He sees where all this is heading with his cross.
And he looks at his at this enemy, which is death.
He's he's he's angry.
And in this, we also see that he's not somebody who just feels sadness
and is unable to do something about it.
He sees the worst things you can go through seeing somebody you love suffer
and not being able to do anything about it.
He sees us in our sadness.
He weeps with us, but he's deeply moved and can do something about it.
He can bring transformation.
So he came with tears, but he also came fourthly and lastly
to bring transformation to bring true change.
So Jesus doesn't just comfort us in our grief.
He brings it to our resolve and he brings about the change that is needed.
So in the next scene, Jesus deeply moved comes to the tomb.
He says, take away the stone.
They say, well, Martha says he's been dead for days.
He's going to smell.
She's not fully grasped what he told her earlier about himself that her brother will rise.
He says to her, did I not tell you that if you believed you will see the glory of God?
They roll away the stone from the mouth of the cave that was being used as a tomb.
Then notice what Jesus says.
He says two things.
One is he says a prayer.
He prays and what he prays shows that he had actually already been praying.
Now he's praying aloud in a way that invites people into the reality of what is going on here.
He thanks his father.
He prays that those around him would be brought to faith in him.
He prays in a way that is inviting everybody around him into the life of God,
into this deeper reality that is taking place.
He says this prayer and then he speaks a command.
He says Lazarus with a loud voice.
Lazarus, come forth.
What happens?
Lazarus instantly rises from the dead.
When Jesus speaks, the dead are raised to life.
I've heard it said many times before that if he didn't specify Lazarus,
every single grave would have opened and everybody would have come out.
Here's the thing, if he did it for Lazarus, he can do it for anyone.
Somebody might say, well, I'm not dead yet.
What do you mean?
He can raise me.
Well, Scripture actually teaches that we are dead spiritually before we come to know Jesus.
Death separates us, physical death separates us from life in this world,
but spiritual death separates us from God.
And that is our condition, apart from Christ.
And that will be our condition forever if we die without Christ,
because he is the life, he's the source of life.
Jesus gives eternal life.
We see that here, but we also hear Jesus earlier in the Gospel of John.
Say, truly, truly, I say to you, whoever hears my word, whoever hears my word
and believes him who sent me has eternal life.
So like Lazarus, we are all invited to hear Jesus calling us to come forth.
He says that those who put their faith in him have eternal life,
and this life goes on forever.
So when we face death, it will not be the end.
If our faith has been in Jesus, we will go to be with Christ one day.
When we face death, we will be then welcomed by Jesus.
And faith in Jesus isn't just believing that certain facts about Jesus are true.
Once again, it is coming to the person of Jesus.
But also we know that Jesus will bring about a final resurrection.
In John 5, Jesus said, truly, I say to you, an hour is coming
and is now here when the dead will hear the voice of the Son of God.
And those who hear will live.
So ultimately, Jesus didn't come just to take us out of this broken world.
Right? Our final hope isn't just that we will die and leave this world
and go to be with Jesus somewhere in heaven.
Our ultimate hope is that Jesus has come to restore and to redeem this broken world.
And there's coming a day when one day Jesus will say,
come forth and the dead in Christ will rise.
And everything that is sad will become untrue and every promise will be fulfilled.
And we will live with him forevermore.
The promise is that we will be with Christ forever in a new creation.
We will dwell with him forever in that place without sickness,
without death and all of the brokenness we see and feel.
So his coming may feel delayed.
If that's going to happen when Jesus returns, we might think,
well, it'd be great if he turned up now.
I'm still feeling sickness now or I've gone through this time of grief now.
It'd be great if he turned up. Why does he delay?
Well, Scripture is clear about that.
He delays his coming so that more and more people will come to know him
and have life in him and be with him forevermore.
He's not willing that any should perish but that all should come to repentance.
He delays out of love for us.
So what's the response?
What is our response?
Well, we read later on in John 11 that many people believed in Jesus,
but others went to go speak to the Pharisees
and then this plot was made to put Jesus to death.
And that's what happens. Jesus dies.
He was laid in a tomb and hope seemed to be lost.
There was a delay.
His delay was motivated by love.
Three days later, he rose again from the dead.
Death could not hold the one who is the resurrection and the life.
So how are we responding to the risen Jesus?
How are you responding today?
Jesus asked Martha an important question that we read
and I want to ask you that question.
Do you believe this?
Do you believe that Jesus is the resurrection and the life?
Have you put your faith in Jesus?
Why not reach out the empty hand of faith
to receive the gift of life that he offers you in himself?
The question is also not have we believed in Jesus at some point
but also are we trusting in him now,
even in the midst of our disappointments?
What does faith look like in the midst of grief?
It looks like bringing it to him.
Faith in Jesus doesn't mean that we no longer know
any disappointments in this life
but it does mean that we know where to bring them.
We know where to bring our tears.
We know where to bring our disappointment.
We know where our ultimate hope is found.
It is found in Jesus.
And we can know whatever we're going through
that he loved us enough to suffer for us,
speak the truth to us,
even weep with us
and even die and rise again
that we might have life forevermore.
Let's pray.
Life for us to all just pause in this moment,
take a moment in silence
to personally respond to God in prayer
right where you're sent.
Lord, you are love and you are life.
Lord, I pray that you would help us
to hear your voice calling us to come.
We would trust in you
and we would follow you on this path of life
that you have laid before us.
I pray that you would draw each one of us to yourself.
Lord, for those who doubt,
I pray that you'd give faith.
For those who mourn,
I pray that you would give hope.
Lord, may we all know your love,
an ever-deepening measure.
In Jesus' name, amen.